i ragazzi per meglio come sono e se non
fai già oggi siano dati soffocando
episodio 3 stenteremo le vocali kraken
let's go allora ragazzi siete pronti per
evocare solcherà che già abbiamo fallito
nel secondo episodio a provare a
evocarlo ma adesso ci proviamo allora il
mondo per evocare il crack che i
passaggi sono difficili e non sempre
usciti la prima volta
ok ma vuoi prenderlo per dopo vorrei mi
coperti lo prendi lo prendi nozze me non
lascia bello pre insieme a cavallo
io credo che tu per scappare la forza
rievoca questo con i diamanti una volta
ha permesso a carena morire che sparare
acqua
dobbiamo sparare acqua e dinho non ha
sparato a te ok ok raio buona questa
entra assolutamente da ok perfetto ok
eravamo arrivati qua dobbiamo sparare
acqua su stato rilevato tutto ci faremo
dai strada faremo tuo prometto aspetta
io non mi fido di te non sprechiamo vita
io sono forte
bravissimo ora devi tornare da noi paolo
ragazzi difficilissimo prendi la
ringhiera che non casinò eccoci dai non
mi fido di me stesso aspetto che il
premier in carta più grande ok
fatelo voi laga riuscite c questo
semplice il problema in territorio il
ritorno renzino trame ma certo perché
provato malaria gli spara da lividi se
ci arriva la pro cipro cpc sparando da
lisbona comperiamo station domando
perfetto entrati subito fair
ok allora io non mi muovo da qui
solo se per rimuovere ci provo parola
chiave per o meno la chiameremo già devi
rimanere assolutamente sulla barca
perché sennò poi si allagano riesci stai
la chiave è che la cosa più programmi di
stefano che ha niente da perdere
no ma se io moglie finita ma è vero non
morire gravissimo il fatto mai a
riacchiappare spinge verso avanti e
spinge verso avanti esatto non si vuole
alta salva ok bravissimo
non perfetti piano piano va bene brava
brava prima chiave che avevamo prima
renault perché occorre di ritornare ecco
la chiama morire stesso mai fare ma
tutti da chi applica la chiave la piena
entra subito entra entra secret che
stroncano c'è un altro passaggio di
cos'è sta roba dobbiamo tirare le due
leve per far scendere la barca ma stimo
tirate perfetto dovevo sapere veloci
vorrei cadere in acqua
non perdete la mia secret exit bene
eccolo eccolo allora e ora dobbiamo
affrontare il crati e non sull'uomo che
a livello vita una vita dura vita
e vero la vita dobbiamo spararli
sparagli picchiare evoca le cose occhio
ai una bomba sotto lo so ora che
orribile devo farmi armi ci sono armi
come fai picchiarlo con slava ma che in
mamma mia quanto è forte
voglio batterlo voglio batterlo tokyo
sta facendo ragazzi o mio dio azione no
non morire step cosa stai facendo un
culturista
anche difficili sta tornando sta
tornando e pavimento non è vero ma ci
credo sei tifosi vorrei farlo fuori non
è finita devi toccare la bomba e faye
l'esplodere ok tocca le scappa che è un
fatto non cadere in un canalone per
chiedere tocca la bomba però non lancia
gli ha subito lasciargli la via via
bravissimi ma dove gli allevatori
legalità navi tridente cliente picchia
lo vado ma no vabbè ma ragazzi
impossibile c'è il granchio che la
pistola ragazzi gravi episodi granchi
che mi deve mollare
c'è il jetpack meglio subito premio il
granchio mi deve mollare
oggi ore grazie amico sua guarda che si
sta perdendo bora bora entra nel aiutate
da te la zattera piano piano piano le
proporzioni ci abbia provato va bene
sono contento io litigo evocare la
mascotte bellissimo bellissimo
bellissimo e vabbè allora facciamo se
non puoi batterli unisciti a loro c'è
l'unico modo per evitare questa è fa e
andare nel sito ed ex per i 23 novembre
mi diverto sento impegnato secret exit
ce l'ha fatta la torta il polipo
benissimo poiché il crack e non è
ovviamente tecnicamente nuvole ok ma non
venire qua è il punto al dovere
anche io non riesco a fare questa cosa
che ho problemi io un caffè provare a
volare da schizzato e pericoloso amy
sarebbe perfetto ma non è possibile
io non è vero in tutto questo è casuale
martello hamas il prossimo quesito
niente moio adesso stai portando giu
stai portando già mandate giusto vedo
niente neanche io non sono fatto non
muori
cosa stai facendo lato sopra la
mongolfiera è proprio questo gioco è
bellissimo c'è il profumo non coniglio
non ci credo la mia vita è brutta o
stavolta ne voglio sapere
non ci credi io la mia vita non ci posso
credere più nella mia vita non ci posso
credere suo livello e non esca farlo
muoio sempre nemico spendendo da sola
così così no
ma cosa succede
ma cos'è successo ma come con che fisica
poi mio dio perfetto volatile del
treviso non lo sai non avrai vinta non
l'avrei vinta non l'avrei vinta
ok
ecco è troppo potente questi veicoli o
magath la bomba lauder non usare ucciso
non ci credo se mi fatti così
ma tu cos'hai fatto occhio granata
no non ci posso credere ragazzi mi ha
buttato mi ha avuto mia mi ha messo
fuori uso lover board no no
sei stato un valoroso avversario che ti
dà un'altra possibilità mi piace questo
cos'è cos'è sta roba
non lo so sono quattro bombe 5 è
impossibile attenzione oggi è ora
diventa difficile schivarle una bus
pascal casasola ci penso fiducioso fusto
di un cosa anzi fare di meglio
e ora che il gioco incredibile se li è
stato fortissimo e basta che ti aggrappi
di bruto xv la ribalta la situazione io
ribatto perfetta fatta brava fair è
bravissima
te lo meriti di essere schiacciato oddio
non vedo l'ora che scendi caro non
scenderò il mio delegato la lista
abbastanza farmi fuori dovresti spararmi
fuori con tutto incluso
ma perché lo sono di armi in quanto
tempo per suonare armi niente 54 a una
certa è volato mancosu permette a
chiamare
mamma mia ragazzi ma lancia gara per la
carlucci aia lo schema ma non c'è uno
spiraglio non sa come chiuderla deve
aspettare anche il dolore ci sono tutte
le armi del gioco e vanno a pu gli 89 a
nokia ma che mira
ciao bella e basta meglio ci giocherei
veramente tutto il giorno proviamo con
razzo ragazzi però che questo video sia
piaciuto fateci sapere se vole dal trio
di avocado lasciate un bel like il video
vi è piaciuto cliccate attaccati stefano
ma non fare così io non ci voglio
credere iscritti al canale schiacciate
il tasto per iscrivervi con la campania
la perchè rimetta i dati sono uscite
passate anche ai caraibi seppe fare e
noi come sempre ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo
ora non chiudo il video finché non ci
vediamo va bene va bene dai
chiediamo tutto dai ragazzi
[Musica]